foreign
hey guys welcome to an absolute
legendary episode of congratulations
[Music]
too long Beard's too long Beard's too
long and it's all good need to need to
trim it up only getting gray on this
side so that's actually kind of BS need
to get the gray on the both sides and I
wouldn't mind getting the gray on the
you know on the side over here be kind
of cool dude be like the doctor strange
of Comedy
um yeah dude we're having a good time uh
we got dates coming up here in
um we are going to be in
Brea actually we're going to be at the
Brea Improv uh just doing uh getting the
Reps back in because I haven't been on
stage for a bit uh
um Portland Oregon January 20th Seattle
Washington the first one sold out second
one is January 22nd Lakeland Florida
Daytona Beach Florida Jacksonville
Florida San Antonio Sugarland New
Orleans Providence Newark New York uh
Chicago anyway a bunch of different
shows but we also are announcing
um uh Utah I'm gonna be in Salt Lake
City and there's another one too is it
is it somewhere up Michigan somewhere in
Michigan I don't know Chrisley Milwaukee
there it is chrisley.com tickets are
pre-sale or uh general public at this
point I don't know when you're looking
but um but there we go Milwaukee and
also Utah and Salt Lake City we love
performing in Salt Lake City another we
love performing in in
um
Milwaukee as well uh uh I uh so go to
chrisley.com get the tickets you know
what I mean uh we have a good time it's
a little loosey-goosey we're having a
you know you know uh you know it's all
good my baby
um the boy's sleeping right now put him
in the crib didn't sleep for two hours
then we were gonna go get him and then
he fell asleep so we're like okay guys
just spent he's gonna get [ __ ] bed
sores he's just gonna be in bed so long
but um he won't stop picking his scab
all good had it for a month
so um what do you do I put a Band-Aid on
it and then you put the Band-Aid on it
and it gets all the adhesion [ __ ] uh
the chafing and [ __ ] it's just a big
mess
but uh oh whoops
almost uh
oh yeah almost sucked in my tongue down
my esophagus that's cool
um but we're having a good time here we
were in San Diego or as my mom would say
San Diego don't know why she would say
it she's an insane person but um
we were in San Diego doing shows I was
doing shows with Denny love and Lula
Gonzalez two really a great uh comedians
that are rising stars in comedy and they
were uh doing the show they went on
before me and we did three shows in in
San Diego and it was absolutely [ __ ]
unbelievable dude we love San Diego we
really turned a leaf over on San Diego
because I didn't really love playing in
San Diego uh and then I realized that it
was probably because when you play clubs
in San Diego everyone gets super drunk
at clubs and then also when you play the
House of Blues in San Diego that's a
rock venue so it's a music venue and and
it absolutely sucks sucks donkey balls
when you play it uh as a comedian
because people are just like [ __ ]
sitting at high top tables and just
drunk as [ __ ] but San Diego people get
drunk as [ __ ] dude it's so San Diego to
be like this if you're a guy oh that's
classic when something's not even
classic you know like they're not
talking about Citizen Kane you know what
I mean they're just talking about the
way a guy eats a cheeseburger or
something dude have you seen
have you seen Josh have you seen him eat
the eat of eat the [ __ ] that the an
animal style
at in and out CL it's classic dude
really why just the way he does it man
no cap okay cool everyone in San Diego
has ties to you know some sort of that
they were in the military or the Navy or
some [ __ ] it's unbelievable I don't make
the rules but that's what it is and uh
every single woman there has a [ __ ]
tattoo so there's nothing it's just
there is The Classy version of San Diego
too The Classy version of San Diego is
basically La Jolla and that sucks worse
so but you know what I mean it's like
they think they're holier than thou but
it's all good but San Diego really came
through and we had such a good time we
did three shows sold over 3500 tickets
Whoopsie Daisy all good and you know
what I mean couldn't keep them sitting
in their seats they were standing what
am I gonna do do it I gave him [ __ ]
hot [ __ ] they wanted hot [ __ ] I give him
hot [ __ ] you know priced up my tickets a
little bit babies so I had to give him
the hot [ __ ] and I do do it but he also
gets really vulnerable and gets [ __ ]
real right because he has to because he
does because that's good for him and
it's just it's just [ __ ] nice you
know you you know it's like I go in and
I know how to [ __ ] make people laugh
but also I want to [ __ ] you know
sometimes I just want to sit on the
stool and guess what it's story time
yeah dude talk about my inner demons
talk about the [ __ ] walls down but uh
so come on out and see a show dude the
Don't Push Me Tour is absolutely Bonkers
we're having such a good time check out
the Vlogs over on the channel the
kristalia channel we are putting the San
uh the San Diego one up soon
uh so you could check it out uh but
we've been having a really good time God
my voice is great it's got a lot of soda
in it right now you know why because I
haven't been doing stand up for two
months so I did three shows and after
the first two shows on the Saturday my
voice was gone dude and I started
selling Center really nice dude because
I'm talking really nice I'm talking like
Viggo Mortensen in History of Violence
nice like I had a real soda in my voice
like I'm not Sam Elliott but I'm Vigo
Mortensen in [ __ ] The History of
Violence right like just kind of gravely
just like someone just kicked rocks up
into my mouth and they bounced off my
palate and just went down my esophagus
and then they just started kind of
speaking and people were like whoa whoa
whoa whoa It's really it's gonna be that
sexy and I'm just like guess so
guess so I got no control over my own
voice I mean I can make it do things but
when I'm just relaxed and just chilling
this is what it is you're welcome for
the refreshing drink there's soda in my
voice
um so yeah so that's what happens when
you do three shows after not doing them
for two months you start sounding a
little bit too much cool and uh so I am
sounding a little bit too much cool and
uh you know what I mean ladies I'm sorry
for the wetness I I I basically
um should hand out towels at my shows
it's fine dude I um
I thought I was gonna [ __ ] it up I
thought I was gonna [ __ ] up my show
because I haven't done it for two months
and I've never not performed for that
long except for when I was starting from
scratch after that like in 2020 took a
break for a year and then I started from
scratch but I had an act that was I
already was doing and then stopped for
two months and then had to basically
do the the the
um show
that I was doing already and I didn't
think about it when I was not
working
for two months
once
didn't think about it once also it's
crazy when you're gone and just immersed
in like a therapeutic environment the
[ __ ] that you don't think about once
dude I was there and I would be like you
know when you let you know when you're
in high school and you leave high school
and you're like man these guys I'll
probably know a lot of these guys for a
long time and then [ __ ] nine years
later you're like oh yeah Chris benino
what the [ __ ] ever happened to that guy
totally forgot about him
that's what it's like when you're there
in a therapeutic environment for for
over a month you just don't think about
people like some of your best friends
and it's like really like okay but also
also
is it are they important in your life so
then you're going through this thing and
we're just like well but yeah they are
but maybe you're just you know dealing
with your own [ __ ] and that's fine dude
you get to take breaks from friendships
I fully believe that you get to take
breaks from friendships
um I don't even really I haven't
honestly I haven't been wanting to hang
out with anyone lately and that's weird
for me man I love weirdos and I love
[ __ ] being you know hanging with
people that just I got no business
hanging out with just like weirdos like
uh people that you know my wife or or
somebody might be like who is that guy
and I'm just like that's my buddy Troy
and he's just like some troglodyte
wearing a [ __ ] uh Vince Carter Jersey
you know with hair on his [ __ ]
shoulders
dude Vince Carter jerseys
Vince caught a bomb harder who says that
Jay-Z
Vince Carter
okay
um
dude that is the most insecure laugh and
we all know it and it's all good and
Jay-Z knows it and I know he's probably
heard about this because this podcast is
world renowned dude
um I will not accept that this podcast
is not the best podcast going and I know
that everybody understands that everyone
has their own opinion but when it comes
to the hard-hitting facts
like when like people in San Diego say
classic
and everyone has something to do with
the [ __ ] military or navy and all the
chicks have tattoos
you come to me and also I got a little
bit of a sweet vulnerable side right so
you really you know
that's fine but comment below and just
hook up the algorithm right
hook up the algorithm right
um so yeah we're having a good time in
life and uh you know last episode was a
little bit of a doozy I was talking
about how I was in rehab and we got a
little bit emotional and you know I'm
trying to [ __ ] keep the silly goose
times but I gotta be real don't I babies
oh he's gotta be real dude
he's gotta be real why because he he's
got no choice but to [ __ ] let them
walls down and be real oh god dude is he
real uh was he was he real no was he
real
occasionally but is he real now oh God
he's so real now and dude uh I can't
help it
great
um if you're new listener thank you very
much if you're not a new listener you
listen before send this to your friend
uh we're hooking it up we got the new
merch at uh chrisley.com we're going
over and do some fall colors dude
um so yeah I was in San Diego what did I
do in San Diego drove down to San Diego
you got to drive down is San Diego on
Saturday it takes two hours you drive
down to San Diego from LA on a Friday or
a Thursday
11 hours the traffic is absolutely it's
just so shitty man it's just so [ __ ]
shitty
you know and I try not to look at my
phone when I'm driving because that's
unsafe but it's also what are we doing
here traffic you're being boring as [ __ ]
so it's like I don't watch
Forensic Files on my
phone but I want to right so traffic
let's keep
I want cars to be all locked into a grid
I also think that cars should I'm like I
have some nice cars but I think that
cars should legitimately be just
um
I don't think people should have their
own cars I think you should just go when
you're done at a place find a car
like I think cars should be government
like just like put out there by the
actual State and you just go and you
just don't need key as you go and you
drive home and then when you're home you
take a car and then you drive to work
and when you're at work if somebody took
your car you just go get another car in
the parking lot
everyone would have to have gates in
their homes though you know because then
people would probably steal cars out of
your home and there's probably too many
homeless people that would be stealing
cars never mind scratch that but in
theory it's good and I'm a communist so
I think that that [ __ ] you know
I think that that's great I think that
everyone should have the most equal
amount of money dude
I think that it should be about uh what
do you call it
um
what do you call it
um it should be like Russia are they
Communists I don't know but we come here
to learn we don't come here to learn we
come here to talk about the hard-hitting
issues like pants
um so yeah what's going on over I
haven't heard about Russia in a long
time they still fighting the media will
do some [ __ ] they'll be hanging out
having a good time talking about some
[ __ ] and then they'll just like be like
all right dude we'll get back to you on
like some real big [ __ ] happens but
they're still fighting over there that's
the thing about war I'll tell you right
now
foreign
here's a [ __ ] hot take
War
takes too long
it takes too long
do it
better and way quicker
war is like when I have to go to Target
with my wife
and you know because she's like let's go
I think I'm Gonna Make You the executive
decision that you're going to come and
we're all going to go as a family and
I'm like all right you know I'm like the
[ __ ] Secretary of State or whatever
like I guess if that's really what you
want to do Mrs president my damn
president
and then we go to the [ __ ]
um I'm like the Donald Rumsfeld or
whatever no he's the [ __ ] who gives a
[ __ ] I don't know but like I don't know
much about the government but you know
what I mean I'm trying to paint a
picture and then we go and then I'm just
like she's like looking at dresses and
[ __ ] and it's like this is Target you
look at pots and pans and maybe like a
[ __ ] nose hair clipper
but she's like look at this cute little
pumpkin thing with the straw on it
we should get it for Halloween and I'm
like it's August 5th
but I love it right she's my angel and I
want her to be happy and I want her to
be happy at the [ __ ]
uh
Halloween dude and all the holidays
so it's like okay and yes our Christmas
tree's still up it's January 9th
um what is it January uh ninth
he gets it right on the money folks but
uh he's a mental calendar dude he's a
he's the human calendar step right up
step right up it's the human calendar
he'll guess what day it is all right
or you'll win a stuffed toy
hello sir
hi fella
what day is it January 9th oh it is yeah
yeah so get out of here you don't get a
stuffed toy
[Music]
um like to guess your weight [ __ ] you
know what I mean explaining it too much
but uh yeah dude work takes too long man
it's like
Russia versus Ukraine
they not winning
hey Russia you're too big big
how you not winning
what's it been like eight months
come on man you're not good at War
like
America we got all the Manpower when we
went to in [ __ ] in remember how long
it took when we were in Iraq how are we
not winning dude that took what how long
was that war
remember the first day we were bombing
the [ __ ] out of all all of them and it's
like oh [ __ ] we're winning dude they
called it shock and awe
oh we're winning and then it just kept
going and going like them [ __ ] rides
at Target like the [ __ ] aisles just
all of a sudden the soldiers are in the
goddamn aisle with the what's her name
Daisy Fuentes uh clothing line or
whatever the [ __ ] and the soldiers are
like how the [ __ ] did we get in here I
didn't even know Daisy Fuentes had a
clothing line
another guy's like that's actually how
she makes most of her money most people
think she was a model minimum
no no she has a [ __ ] dig it's also a
cold she's really
she's really in the [ __ ] good at the
trench
she she does a lot of leggings and moms
moms love her [ __ ]
yeah
so does JLo I don't know if you know
that no I know about JLo
yeah so Sergeant hey Sergeant [ __ ]
Sergeant Swanson you know about JLo I do
yeah
oh they got he stood up when he was
talking about JLo they got him oh you
got me
oh you just got me
oh a tip of that just got me Odell
let's watch it again
dude we're going on YouTube and we're
watching it again because it's one of
the funniest clips online it's not even
close to the chocolate croissants videos
but holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
um the samurai oh no Katana Katana blade
fail dude
katana blade stuff QVC man stabbed
himself with the this is the one of the
uh
1816 is the item number on this one so
into it already 1101 18 1960 item on
this one already
dude I can't 1816 is the item number on
this one and the nice thing about these
practice guitarists
oh oh that hurt yeah oh that hurt big
time
a piece of that just the tip just got me
Odell stabbed them you know
so chill oh that got me good all right a
piece of that tip just got me you all
right
[Music]
emergency surgery in the studio
if that guy doesn't root for the Chicago
Bears do you understand us off my arm so
um
we may need emergency surgery
in his studio right now dude King Of The
Hill in in on King of the Hill uh I love
that video that's one of my favorite
videos dude
people came up to me in the show in San
Diego and they were like if you haven't
seen the chocolate croissants video that
I [ __ ] did on my podcast you gotta
look at chocolate croissants crystallia
Google it or um what do you call it
YouTube it but yeah War takes too long
and I want it to be quicker it really
should take too long right because
people shouldn't know it's common I mean
I know we got the defenses and [ __ ] but
like when you're America or you're
Russia or you're China
how the [ __ ] are you not winning in a
day and a half
I don't know
I don't know also you see the [ __ ] they
have out there it's like so you ever
catch the leaked footage of the stuff
it's like whoa bro like drones that are
just like two tons and they they go a
thousand miles an hour it's like
you know I guess I don't know maybe it's
a money thing I can't believe Barbara
Walters died I feel bad about that sad
about Barbara Walters dying but of
course you she was one of those people
that where you're like she's not dead
yet
how old was she 112
how old was Barbara Walters
um but you know Barbara Walters was cool
um
can you tell me what your relationship
with oh bro yes
this one is unreal this was
this woman again
this oh yeah the Donald not Donald just
said what the [ __ ] guy from the
Clippers Sterling Donald Sterling
you tell me what you're this is Donald
Sterling's mistress
girlfriend or some [ __ ]
relationship with Donald Sterling is
Mr Sterling's right hand arm
s
dude
come on but
foreign
's right hand arm Barbara Walter should
have just immediately been like
interview over I have to go right hand
arm dude
I'm so nervous she's got cottonmouth you
know man
here we go I'm Mr Sterling's right hand
arm
man oh dude just talk about shock and
awe dude
talk about shock and awe
I'm Mr Sterling's right hand arm man
nailed it too the way she was Mr
Sterling everything I'm his Confidant
I'm Mr Sterling everything
I'm his confidante his best friend okay
his silly rabbit his what his silly
Barbara Walters dude when someone the
age of Barbara Walters gives you that
real what you know you are in for it
you're done you're done you're in
you're you're digging you don't know
what you're digging what
man
I'm Mr Sterling everything I'm his
Confidant cottonmouth his best friend
his silly rabbit
his what his silly rabbit his silly
rabbit yes is that what he calls you no
ah
dude shut it down dude he's I'm his
silly rabbit what his silly rabbit is
that what he calls you no
dude
unreal I would not expect anything less
from a right arm hand man honestly
what a dunce dude
how'd these chicks getting their time
I get airtime dude
you [ __ ] up marble Walter's Legacy
Barbara Walters is good as [ __ ] and now
this is something that people have to
see after she dies you [ __ ] up
legacies with how dumb you are
what just uh how do you let somebody
like this even be on the air
right
Donald uh Sterling took all the heat
there
this woman
is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's all good
these [ __ ] me the media is insane I
mean what dude they honestly there
should have been a preamble at that
[ __ ] thing
this is actually the weirdest interview
I have ever given
um
I'm glad Jeremy Renner is doing better
in all honesty we thought he wasn't
going to make it they crushed his legs
it crushed his lung it crushed his jaw
it broke his orbital bone I mean this
guy was just I mean if he wasn't Hawkeye
honestly also I didn't know Jimmy Renner
was 51. that's insane to be run over by
a snowman grandma was Run Over by a
Reindeer oh I was at those snowballs no
snow snow
plow what is it snow plow whatever it
was dude
anyway he got run over by a snow plow
snow truck I don't know it was something
way too big that's weighs tons and it's
actually supposed to have a mechanism
that stops
um
running over you if it's running over
you but it didn't so
there you go with the [ __ ] Jeremy
Renner shits uh but he's doing better
that's great
um
I wrote him and I said hey man you know
because obviously he knows about the
podcast because we [ __ ] love Amir but
I said hey man sending love and thinking
about you man
um yeah so it was very sweet and he he
wrote back he's a nice guy but he uh you
know I'm really happy that he's doing
well dude because honestly I'll tell you
this much right now
I don't want to live in a world without
Jeremy Renner
and I mean that I mean that now if
somebody like Jeremy Renner passed I
would be sad
uh I would still go about my life and do
my thing but it's not the world I want
to live in how's that it's not the world
I want to live in
because he's Hawkeye and he's only 51.
dude how do you get run over by a
snowplow actually aren't they slow
yeah it's a whole Fiasco or something
something going on over there
something going on over there I'm gonna
see if there's you know that right you
know I'm a conspiracy theorist now right
they pushed me way over to the right and
I just [ __ ] I'm so right I'm back
over to the left
I go so right I'm I'm awoke I'm so
[ __ ] right I'm woke that's how
[ __ ] it's dude I'm a conspiracy
theory Q what's up Q
I'm into it now that even especially
after it's passe and like it it I mean
now I'm into it
I'm bringing it back that's what I want
dude
[ __ ] yeah dude Q Anon I'm changing it to
q a lot that's I mean it's so much I'm
I'm I want to know that you know what
dude I'll tell you what here's the deal
I don't do interviews on this podcast
except for people I love that are in my
family that I know very much and also a
guy named David Sullivan that's fat but
dude I will tell you right now I will
interview anyone on this podcast that's
in [ __ ] Q Anon reach out to me
foreign
[Music]
let's storm the capital uh again let's
storm Capital Records bro
I'm serious let's just storm let's just
not even let's be General about it
let's just go out and just storm not
even the cap like I get it the capital
thing didn't really work out for you too
well you know you all got arrested and
now that I'm queuing on all good and I'd
say let's count let's let's [ __ ] uh
storm Capital Records but probably
that's a big let's just get out and
storm let's just storm generally let's
storm in a vague way just like
we want whatever we want and we'll keep
chanting it and then we'll decide what
we want we'll do it at like parks and
like on the street and people will be
trying you know what we'll do we'll do
it outside of movie theaters and
premieres and and and and when people
get mad at us we'll be like dude you
can't get mad at us for storming outside
of [ __ ] movie premieres when half of
them got [ __ ] Jason Momoa and 40
other Jason Momo is doing the goddamn
hakka dance
every time Jason Momo is in a movie he's
doing the [ __ ] hakka dance outside
the goddamn thing
ha
and and and and so I can't be queuing on
because of that
I mean I I get you know I understand it
doesn't really make it it's not the same
thing but like dude it it is more
annoying to do the hakka dance outside
of a [ __ ] movie premiere when people
are just trying to get to their seats
and [ __ ] spilling popcorns because they
got a guy who's got shoulder for days
put a week on it wearing a [ __ ]
loincloth moving into him because he's
screaming out
that's more annoying than Q Anon
basically who whatever I don't even know
what culture that is Hawaiian New
Zealand I don't know who the what is it
but Jason Momoa dude it's like
Jason no Noah
you know what I mean just for like a fun
little play on words
so I'm cute and I've been queue for a
while now
honestly uh it has started happening in
2020 the end of it
um after covid when they were like when
when honestly when the when the people
when the doctors came back and were like
okay I guess go outside like huh did you
fix it no that it was nothing then what
the [ __ ] were we doing for nine months
right
so now I'm q and honestly [ __ ] yeah dude
so I want to interview Q people here I'm
serious I'll oh this this is in the
congratulations Studios I will interview
a q Anon person so come on over and
don't be a [ __ ] one either dude I
want the full-on
Joe Biden sheds his skin when he goes in
the ocean queuing on [ __ ]
a Christian
thank you
you know like someone who is like well I
love everyone though but you don't
that Q Anon guy
somebody that goes hey Chan what am I
[ __ ]
20 [ __ ] hey Chan I want the guy with the
new Chan
I want the guy on [ __ ] 11 Chan or
whatever the [ __ ]
I want to be in fear during the
interview
because who knows what could happen
[ __ ] yeah dude
I don't even want Trump to be the
president I want a new
a new a new crazy guy
a new guy that's ju you know who do I
want [ __ ] uh who do I want Kevin
Sorbo that's who I want I want Kevin
Sorbo to that dude is so right I want to
hang the [ __ ] out with Kevin Sorbo and
just get on motorcycles and
dorm
We're Cute huh
I can't hear you we're on a motorcycle
all good man it was so cool when you
were in crawl
but I'm just saying we're both Q I'll
text it to you
oh no he died [ __ ] Tom Hanks killed
him
um
that's my favorite cue is that's what I
want the Tom Hanks eats children kill
guy
they're Tom Hanks eats children the Joe
Biden and Barack Obama
go into the ocean to shed their layer of
skin cue
[ __ ] yeah dude
[Music]
um anyway
shout out to Barbara Walters we love her
man and uh she's dead now and honestly
man I've been at this point where it's
like
uh
uh is death that bad like and I'm not
talking about like I'm not talking about
this is not a serious thing here like
yes I've been suicidal in my life but
I'm not and like
to be uh
uh dead would that be so bad it would be
bad happening but after that
living my life like it's going then
living my life like it's going and
living my life like it's going to
deliver my life like it's golden I mean
dead but not living your life but you
know what I mean but
um
yeah man uh how dude how many R B
singers are there for real they're so
a many man
people Bryson
Peabo
imagine me like excuse me Mr Bryson uh
you could call me Peabo
no
no Mr Bryson dude I met a guy once at a
diner and I said I'm Chris he said hey
nice to meet you I'm seven
and I go where are the other six
he didn't laugh
but it's all good also one time I I was
talking to a woman this was [ __ ]
years ago and she and she and I said oh
really where do you work and she said
beyond the beach and I said oh so like
the ocean
[Music]
did and she said no it's a star and I
was like I know dude all right how dumb
are you are you Donald Sterling's right
hand arm man silly rabbit
I'm his silly rabbit what his silly
rabbit does he call you that no
oh
oh there's only before this moment and
after
I've met the dumbest creation known to
man
um
I don't want to live in a lot I don't
want to live a lot you know Barbara
Walter she did her thing how old is she
by the way did you look her up
93. it's a good age to go to peace out
right
it's a good age to peace out
you know you start getting [ __ ] old
and [ __ ] and you know what I'll tell you
this she looks fantastic
she looked fantastic for a long time she
looked fantastic
um
uh you know you want to go out like Hugh
Hefner right he had the [ __ ] move
dude
just the Playboy Mansion dude and then
right before me too he just goes they're
doing what now
um yeah dude
I'm sorry there's a what there's a
movement for what oh [ __ ] really
oh
dearly beloved
we're gathered here today A guy that
died immediately when he heard about the
metoo movement because obviously he was
going to be me too
Hugh Hefner he's buried in one of his
illustrious robes
um
yo we're in a robe all the time is just
too much right
Pinot Peno
pinu too much
um also hit me up at the Discord uh uh
patreon.com crystallia you can uh hit me
up in the Discord and uh let me know
topics because I like to do that page
isn't available to login
um but that's fine dude
it's all good guess what I did today
went to the [ __ ] coffee being first
time Coffee Bean back from rehab
um because I don't really drink too much
coffee anymore which is crazy dude
because of how
um I don't drink coffee because of how
um
I didn't drink coffee there I just drank
like a half calf in the morning and then
that's it
um and so I think my anxiety I don't
know if my anxiety's not as good but
like um
or not as potent but I'm more chill now
you know
um I wonder if that has to do with not
drinking coffee but we're [ __ ] that
up now aren't we I had one cup in the
morning and then I'm drinking half of
this this is a quad shot over ice
I'm drinking half of it so that's I
guess two shots and one cup of coffee
not so bad because I used to drink 12
shots every day
um and uh you wonder why you shut your
brains out dude after
um
San Diego
the show on Saturday night we went to
this pizza place in Little Italy dude so
funny one of the dudes in rehab kept on
saying you're going to San Diego you got
to hit Little Italy like that's the
[ __ ] funniest thing I've ever heard
of my life you know
one time I heard a guy say oh you're
going to New York you know you got to
check out Central Park swear to God
swear to God he said it
and I was just like oh well yeah but I
don't know man
but anyway I went to Little Italy didn't
even know I was going a little Italy to
try saying that like that
uh and uh went there got some pizza and
it was by the way Mayhem it was mostly
like it was a crystallia book signing
and I felt very fortunate that everyone
in there [ __ ] wanted to get pictures
and say stuff to me but I couldn't
believe it dude you want to know who
kristalia fans are they're people who go
to pizza places to get slices at [ __ ]
12 30 A.M that's a crystallia fan so
when I show up and I want a [ __ ]
mushroom pepperoni slice only because
they don't have straight pepperoni
because I guess that's what's popular
now I gotta get the mushroom shits in it
which is fine you know do it do I like
it
I'm gonna you know I'm gonna douse that
parmesan cheese on it anyway I'm gonna
douse that [ __ ] just sprinkle it like
it's [ __ ] like Tony Montana in that
[ __ ] on his desk when he's just
looking forward with the mountain of
coke on it that's me eating a slice of
[ __ ] pizza with the parmesan cheese
on it
I haven't get rid of put the [ __ ]
thing up there of course so you know
what I'm talking about but yeah dude
um
you walking where's your Parmesan cheese
you know I want parmesan cheese because
I am addicted to parmesan cheese oh yeah
I've got one more question do you've got
do you have pecorino Romano
no oh that's a big mistake you gotta
have pepperino Romano
that is actually something that Al
Pacino would be
a lot of people like parmesan cheese
don't they you know when I was in Italy
I was roaming around the streets and I
noticed the cheese was a little bit of a
different color I asked a guy
what is that he told me pecorino Romano
well I tried it and oh boy
huh
I hate that pecorino Romano
um so yeah so I went in and got pizza
and got three slices like I'm
it's like I'm gonna only eat that
but I felt a little bit of embarrassment
getting a little bit more you know
because everyone else was getting two
pieces and it's like that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
and I was with nine people and they all
got two slices and some of them got one
and I'm like
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] coming from a guy
whose motto is a burger is a snack
right
and I'm no and I would get two pieces
but I'm no [ __ ]
right
so it's like
I got three pieces because I'm no [ __ ]
and then sat down and one of the other
dudes there that was with us that was at
the show that was friends with my
friends there does construction and he
looked at me and he's like we gonna do
another one and I'm like yeah and
because the same time we said cause
we're no [ __ ]
so he said well I'll go get it what
should I get a whole pie and I said Yup
and he got it and I ate three more
pieces
foreign
with pesto on it and it was so damn good
because I don't stop parmesan cheese on
it oh yeah
and then went back to the hotel
and then woke up the next morning and
then
when I'm sitting on the toilet dude
and I know it's gross but dude we don't
shy away from the truth here at this
podcast
we know it's gross but we don't shy away
from it
at this podcast just because it's gross
because it's real okay
so yeah just a lot of and
um and it's all good
um but you know
uh we have a good time and we ate the
pizza and then I woke up and then I
didn't eat till five because I was so
full off that pizza I get a [ __ ] I'm
I'm talking about I feel hungover when I
eat pizza now of course I've never been
hungover but I eat pizza and then I did
a little bit of a Greek salad at 5 00
p.m and then I ate some salmon dude you
guys don't give a [ __ ] about this but
honestly it's my life and I'm telling
you about it
um
get that new life rips merch
crystalia.com we got them fall colors
and rock it out dude
and rock it the frick out
it sure is wild out there
I don't know what to [ __ ] do anymore
with all these [ __ ] all I want to do
is have my family and just live with my
family and then have this next baby and
just [ __ ] love them all and just hold
them and love them all
you know and just just kind of rebuild
man just like love them and just you
know be I don't even dude sometimes I
don't even want to do [ __ ] comedy
anymore I don't even want to do stand up
I just want to [ __ ] be like
I I don't know what I would do like
maybe I could just be like a [ __ ]
inventor or something
like just maybe we could like move to
like Provo and just that could be some
kind of inventor
like invent something that like
holds a book up instead of you having to
hold it up to read it or like
something that [ __ ] Cooks food better
than a microwave I don't know just I
could be like an idea guy
one time I was talking to a guy that was
like how do I get into Hollywood he's
like I want to be an idea guy and I was
just like oh man dude you're gonna be
lucky if you [ __ ] live another eight
years
you're so backwards are you [ __ ]
Donald Sterling's right-hand armed man
come on silly rabbit who calls you that
no one
um
yeah dude
I used to go down [ __ ] remember when
I would tell you I would run the block
over on cold water and Ventura by the
way thanks for listening and I love you
[ __ ] who support me I really do
um
and uh I was watching the uh I was I
used to run that block but I didn't even
realize I kind of used to run a block a
little bit before that
and I don't know if you knew that
because I don't really talk about it
because it was a long time ago and I'm
very forgetful
but I was like 22-23 and I lived in
Burbank and I would always go to the
7-Eleven and sing would hook me up with
whatever I was buying you know Singh was
the guy who worked there obviously his
name was Singh and obviously it was in
7-Eleven and maybe I'm racist but
doesn't matter
uh he was saying and he was really nice
he's probably dead now but the um I used
to go there and then I used to get like
Waters and [ __ ] you know because I don't
drink I would maybe I don't know what I
would get honestly why would I go to
[ __ ] 7-Eleven what was I getting nuts
like who the [ __ ] honestly who goes to
7-Eleven when you just go to a gas
station
um
so I went to I would go to Western Bagel
dude
next to the [ __ ] Savon or whatever it
was the Rite Aid holy [ __ ] man and I
will go get that [ __ ] egg
um
sandwich with the with the with the with
the bacon on it or something bro and the
cheese and the guy would always hook me
up
he would always hook me up he'd be like
it's all good just take it and he was
just an employee there I'm sure he got
fired eventually but I'm talking about
he will hook me up for months I'll go
thanks so much man I take it and I'd
leave and I'd eat it and then I realized
many years later like oh he wanted to
[ __ ] me like that's I guess what that
was right
I guess you want to [ __ ] me
and then I had a buddy who would go to
like during their same amount of time I
had a buddy that would go to this donut
shop and dude this was incredible to me
he would go to this donut shop and he
would he would get a donut and the woman
and he was like oh how do you make the
donuts and they went back to uh the
donuts to look and dude she gave him
oral sex in the back of the donut shop
making the donuts and I was like that's
so gangster dude
and I was like was she hot and he said
nah
and he kept going back and getting
donuts and BJs dude
the life dude donuts and BJs
maybe for a young man but for me I'm
reformed
for me I'm reformed dude
I'm a sober boy man
that's what's up
I'm a sober boy staying faithful baby
that's what's up
love my wife
she's my angel and I didn't like to say
she's my angel because I want her to be
her own Angel and for me to you know but
she was like no I like when you say that
so I'm like you're gonna get no argument
from here baby
um shout out to happy couples man
I need couple friends man I was talking
to my buddy John DeWalt and like you
know he's married I'm like dude we gotta
hang out we gotta have couple because
like
um
because we gotta do uh we gotta do
because like dude you get to an age
where you're like I'm 42 and it's like I
got down I got [ __ ] two I got another
kid coming and it's like
dude I I we got a [ __ ]
like a going out when people are like
you want to go out
like people come up to me after the show
fans and they're like what are you doing
later and I'm like
nothing
gonna be alone and sad you
because I got to be alone and sad now I
can't just be [ __ ] you know I used to
be uh
all in my phone all distracting myself
trying to get them dopamine hits you
know I'll watch them a little bit of
NCIS I'm not gonna lie on Whoopsie Daisy
if you want to call that a [ __ ]
relapse that's a relapse but I love NCIS
I love NCIS New Orleans
you know and I watched that [ __ ] and I
put that on and I put on Pawn Stars Pawn
Stars with a w
um
yeah dude
and uh and I get my dopamine hits that
way now and it is what it is but gotta
stay strong for the family baby
um
I do I go back and forth between
depression and also feeling good and
like trying to move forward and and be
good and it's uh you know it's different
it's tough but it's all good
thank you
um and we have a good time we have a
good time
it's my wife's birthday today and uh
happy birthday my wife my love I got uh
she she got to chill on the couch and do
all that I went to go get her a coffee I
got a peppermint [ __ ] mocha for her
she slurped that down she probably took
[ __ ] three sips all good and uh she
ate four ice cream little bars and she
was just having a day dude just chilling
watching season two a White Lotus
triggering
and watching season two a White Lotus
triggering but watched it without me by
the way I was gone for two days in San
Diego came back she started already on
episode seven and I Gotta See [ __ ]
and uh so yeah so gotta watch out by
myself I guess now
it's White Lotus season one is [ __ ]
hilarious that guy uh oh dude we gave
Calvin his last gift we forgot it it was
under the tree and we just looked at it
and he was like
can I open this and I was like sure and
he goes but that's what he does when he
gets excited he was opening the guest
gift and he goes like this he says oh my
God this is what I I wanted from my book
and he would say because he pointed at
it in the catalog and we got it from him
from the catalog and then he pulled it
out and he was like what is this and I
said oh it's a monster weighing station
that weighs uh weight and you could
learn numbers that way and he says that
is hilarious
and it's just like dude you're having a
conversation like an exchange student
but it's so adorable man
and it was hilarious and mostly because
he was making it hilarious open that
door it's hot as [ __ ] yeah open the door
it's hot as [ __ ] it's like we all have
[ __ ] wetsuits on it's so hot
um
but yeah man love that boy love being a
dad put a Band-Aid on him and nap so he
wouldn't pick up the pick out the [ __ ]
and uh hopefully that'll be okay uh
yeah man we gave him that and he got so
[ __ ] excited dude seeing my son
excited is the absolute best
it's the absolute best
nothing better
um yeah
we love it
uh I guess that's that dude we had a
good time so we're gonna be [ __ ]
killing it doing another episode we got
the patreon episode coming up uh sign up
on our patreon uh patreon.com crystalia
we got the patreon ads coming up and oh
I'm gonna be in uh Utah pre-sale don't
push me but or maybe it's not pre-sell
anymore if you're listening to it
because I think it goes live tomorrow
and then it'll be out yeah cool so uh
but we got a bunch of you know a bunch
of different ones coming up we got
um
uh let's see we got Brea California I
added a show just the other day Sunday
we got Portland Oregon Seattle
Washington uh uh on the first one sold
out January 22nd Lakeland Florida
Daytona Beach Florida Jacksonville
Florida San Antonio Texas Sugarland
Texas New Orleans Providence Rhode
Island New York New York uh uh Chicago
Illinois look at all these beautiful
Midland Minneapolis too chrisley.com
love it and Boise May 19th but still
even more a lot of a lot of them in Ohio
whatever but you check it out
um you guys thank you for listening we
love that you support like And subscribe
also dude uh subscribe dude my buddy hit
me up and he was like dude this is
[ __ ] up I actually am subscribed to
your channel and I looked and they
unsubscribed me I don't know what's
going on but there's like a [ __ ]
Shadow band we're changing the name it's
not going to be super cult anymore
because obviously it's been a year and
we haven't gained one subscriber so
um yeah subscribe hit the [ __ ]
comments for the algorithm hook it up my
babe dude and send this video to a
friend say Hey you ever heard of
congratulations [ __ ] take a listen
that's the [ __ ] uh job of the cult my
babies so uh let's have a good time this
week everybody I love you and keep your
head up uh crazy times out there it's
raining all over the city but we're
keeping it real all right bye bye guys
and thanks that's the end of the episode
for YouTube if you want to catch the raw
uncut version the uh the one that is uh
uncensored and uh it's just Bonkers
crazy going over to patreon.com Chris
Delia uh you get the extra comment extra
content there's actually about uh 20
episodes right now if you sign up you
can go watch and it's just six bucks so
go and have fun guys patreon.com
crystalia thank you very much
[Music]
thank you
[Music]